Thông thống Israel nóng y ra thế gió ngày 1,729, tâm chính thức Australia măng việc ngay lật tức tới 8 miệnh bó đi
Nơi sẽ ra vụ sạx suông trong lệ hãn nước ca, hụi tảng 12 kẻ mùi lòng người trên mạm
Này cũng là vụ sạx suông nghiêm trong nhất tại Australia trong 7,5 kła
Truyên thâm được thực hiện theo lời mời của tụ tưởng chú nhá, tụi đi à ban y s, giám thế hiện sự loa and kết
Bởi cộng đồng gió thái Australia sau sự việc ở trên đồng giữa tại 8 miệnh bó đi
Hông hợp đặt bảong mơ tưởng nghiệp, gặp gặp gà dựng đặt nhận và người xong sốt
Đông thường nhìn mạch vụ tình công không chỉ nhấm phòng người xó thái mạch của bảo gà dạch chiến trình
Thương xó tồn ra 5 phòng giá quan người của Australia
Bên gặp đỏ trên thâm phụ vụ phải phản nguyên trái chiều
Một xô tổ trực xó thái tập điện tại Australia kia gọi rủy lên mời trong khi các nhỏ uống hộn
Mời steam đã lên kết hát đều tin, gà vụ hông hợp hợp ở Israel lứng đằng sau thường bông dân thường ở giá gặp
Trong khi cơ gặp thảo lếu thang, cạnh xác sinh này trên khai khoảng bằng ít xí quan
Át dụng các bạn phát ăn những đặc biệt và cơ gó ăn người bởi tình tương thủ hướng rất
Nhằm bảo đảm át tỏng công cộng trong xuất chuyến thâm của tổng thống Israel